[Musica]
siete pronti per il vostro momento
morandi e non mi riferisco alla presenza
al festival di sanremo e non penso alle
vostre performance canora e sotto la
doccia o i vostri video su tik tok
penso a un momento diverso dal momento
in cui sarete proiettati sul
palcoscenico della crisi il momento in
cui la terra sotto i vostri previ piedi
cederà il momento in cui il mondo vi
crollerà addosso il momento in cui
qualcuno vi metterà contro voglia
nella lavatrice e schiaccerà il bottone
della centrifuga e quando uscirete
avrete perso tutti i vostri punti di
riferimento questo è un momento morandi
i momenti morandi non toccano solo le
imprese toccano tutti noi e nella nostra
vita quotidiana
la cattiva notizia è proprio questo un
amico malato
una morte in famiglia
la morte di un figlio e anche le imprese
magari un collaboratore disonesto un
mercato che improvvisamente scompare e
anche le istituzioni le crisi toccano
tutti quando parliamo di questi
argomenti
di solito ci sono delle reazioni che
tutti noi immediatamente
così abbiamo istintivamente allora
facevo un piccolo test insieme non vi
vedo molto bene ma proviamo a farlo lo
stesso e mentre vi parlavo di queste
cose che non sono cose evidentemente
gradevoli sicuramente vi saranno passati
dei pensieri per la testa e forse
qualcuno avrà anche commesso qualche
gesto non so quanti tra voi potete
alzare le mani quanti tra voi hanno
pensato o anno sotto la sedia che hanno
fatto questo gesto pochi allora forse
altri avranno fatto questo
un pochettino meno elegante o pechino
più di genere da due gesti che un nostro
ex primo ministro diciamo utilizzava
abbastanza frequentemente e poi forse
vedo che se non questo non è la vostra
linea culturale
e allora forse voi rientrate in questa
categoria
nella categoria di chi si tiene in tasca
magari sullo specchietto retrovisore
dell'auto un cornetto sarete forse
sorpresi di sapere che in questi tre
atteggiamenti ce n'è uno che è
particolarmente virtuoso e non so se
qualcuno vuole provare indovinare se no
me lo dico io l'atteggiamento virtuoso e
il terzo perché è un atteggiamento
virtuoso perché se voi avete deciso di
andare dal tabaccaio o su amazon e
spendere 2 euro per comprarvi un
cornetto portafortuna
vuol dire che vi siete posti un problema
vi siete posti una domanda quando mi si
chiede come ci si prepara alla gestione
di crisi
dico sempre che il punto di partenza è
quello di farsi un film più farsi un
film in testa e questo film non è una
commedia questo film ahimè è un film
dell'orrore consapevoli che la realtà
sarà molto superiore alla vostra
immaginazione
il punto di partenza di questo film è
una domanda ed è una domanda solo what
if
che cosa succede se che cosa faccio se è
una domanda molto semplice
ce la possiamo fare quotidianamente
io ho iniziato a farmela ho iniziato a
pensare quando mi sono sposato non
subito evidentemente da un pochettino
più in là che cosa avrei fatto se fosse
successo qualche cosa a mia moglie ho a
mia figlia
le due persone in assoluto più
importanti per me e questo è un pensiero
molto difficile da gestire
non c'è una risposta non c'è un film che
tu puoi proiettare davanti a questo
e allora un giorno ho smesso di
chiedermi che cosa avrei fatto io ho
iniziato a chiedermi che cosa avrebbero
fatto loro ho iniziato a pensare come
sarebbero state le ore i giorni le
settimane i mesi dopo
e allora mi sono detto c'è qualcosa che
posso fare per aiutare dio non voglia in
una situazione così drammatica e
tremenda e dolorosa
allora ho preso una penna ho preso un
foglio di carta
l'ho scritto mia moglie un messaggio
l'ho chiuso promesso in un cassetto e
lei sa perfettamente dove quella busta
in quella busta
logicamente ci sono delle parole d amore
sono le parole che un marito scambia con
una moglie e poi ci sono delle altre
cose ci sono delle istruzioni chi è
l'avvocato chi è il commercialista
dove sono i conti in banca chi è
l'assicuratore perché spesso ci
dimentichiamo che nei momenti morandi
perdiamo tutti i punti di riferimento
che a loro pensato che questo poteva
essere un piccolo aiuto un piccolo
contributo
per aiutarla
ripeto spero di no ma nella vita non si
può mai sapere da superare quel momento
perché ho iniziato ad occuparmi di
questa tematica
ho iniziato a pormi la domanda del
motivo non subito pochettino più avanti
ma il giorno preciso el 8 ottobre del
2000 euro
e incredibile come so se qualcuno di voi
ha avuto l'esperienza di vivere un
momento veramente difficile della
propria vita come in quei momenti
veramente non sai dove guardare quel
giorno 8 ottobre 2001
me lo ricordo come fosse ieri ma non mi
ricordo tutto il giorno e non mi ricordo
i giorni successivi
quello che è incredibile che in questi
momenti che restano in mente delle
polaroid degli istanti delle sensazioni
e allora oggi pensato che poteva essere
utile condividere con voi
quello che io ho vissuto quel giorno
l'otto ottobre del 2001 e uno mi sono
alzato alle 6 del mattino come faceva
oramai da tre anni da quando mio papà se
n'era andato e mi ero buttato nel lavoro
e uscì di casa come facevo ogni mattina
e attraversare la strada per andare a
prendere il cappuccino e cornetto al bar
e quel giorno c'era una nebbia come
quelle che conosciamo
qui dalle nostre parti che tagliava con
un coltello non si vedeva da un lato
all'altro della strada e poi alle undici
e mezza
ero seduto alla mia scrivania in ufficio
squilla il telefono e ricevo una
chiamata dalle linee aeree scandinave
dalla sas mi chiede se posso
urgentemente andare a linate
e allora raccolgo il computer
chiedo un paio di colleghi di seguirmi
saliamo in macchina e ci dirigiamo verso
l'aeroporto di linate
la prima polaroid e viale forlanini in
viale forlanini completamente deserto
non c'è traffico non c'è nessuno
arriviamo davanti all'ingresso
dell'aeroporto di linate e cioè una
pattuglia dei carabinieri di traverso
che blocca la strada ci qualifichiamo e
arriviamo davanti all'aerostazione
scendo dall'auto
alzo gli occhi guardo il cielo un cielo
blu profondo con un sole forte e penso e
penso alla mattina
penso a quella nebbia che si tagliava
col coltello e tutto d'un tratto una
giornata meravigliosa mi guardo intorno
non si muove niente non so se ricordate
un telefilm di fantascienza che si
chiamava ufo dove c'era un comandante
comandante strucker e c'è un episodio di
questo film dove lui è in movimento e
tutte le persone tutte le cose intorno a
lui sono assolutamente immobili questa
era la scena alla quale io ho assistito
arrivando linate
una scena assolutamente surreale un
aeroporto deserto e silenzioso e poi gli
odori gli odori e incredibile fateci
caso ti restano impressi nella mente e
non vanno più via
l'odore del cherosene nell'aria l'odore
di bruciato
l'odore di schiumogeni dei vigili del
fuoco una sensazione incredibile che mi
porterò dietro tutta la vita entrando
nella rotazione
stavo quante volte sono entrato in
questo aeroporto quante volte ho preso
questi a ieri la vita dell'aeroporto
viva gli annunci degli imbarchi check in
le persone che comprano i giornali chi
beve cappuccino il caffè l'aperitivo il
pranzo sono luoghi di vita e questo era
un aeroporto deserto mi avvio verso gli
ascensori per salire al piano ammezzato
dove c'erano gli uffici delle compagnie
aeree e tutto d'un tratto così con la
coda dell'occhio vedo verso destra un
corridoio male illuminato e vedo delle
ombre che si muovono in questo corridoio
ma purtroppo non sono delle ombre sono i
familiari alcuni dei familiari
618 delle 118 vittime di linate che
vagano in questo aeroporto senza meta
alla ricerca dei loro cari
paola rota aveva vent'anni
i suoi genitori erano su quella ero e
c'era anche un fratellino paola mi
chiamò dopo due anni due anni dopo mi
chiamò in ufficio e mi disse vorrei
venire incontrarla più che volentieri
arrivo in ufficio si sedette davanti a
me mi guardò negli occhi e mi disse io
sto preparando la tesi sull'incidente di
linate sono venuta per raccogliere delle
informazioni che eravamo fuori falloni
le spiegai tutto il lavoro che noi a
supporto della compagnia era avevamo
svolto e non potrei non pestare
impressionato dalla forza di questa
ragazza che dopo quella tragedia aveva
deciso di fare la sua tesi su quell
incidente forse un modo per superare
lotto paola non c'è più
dieci anni più tardi aula si è tolta la
vita
penso e ripenso a quel corridoio
divinato quel silenzio e mi chiedo
perché quel silenzio non è stato
riempito di comunicazione perché nessuno
si è preoccupato di spendere delle
parole di accoglienza di affetto e
vicinanza e la comunicazione non è solo
parole
la comunicazione è anche fatta di gesti
un abbraccio una stretta di mano una
carezza una lacrima a linate
purtroppo quel giorno non ci fu nulla di
tutto questo perché me lo sono chiesto
per tanti anni mi sono chiesto perché
quel silenzio in quel corridoio di
linate
perché nessuno ad accogliere quelle
persone in sofferenza mi sono dato due
risposte
la prima è che nessuno si era fatto
quella domanda what if
cosa facciamo
se c'è un incidente aereo come ci
organizziamo
nessuno al di fuori della compagnia era
si era posto con la domanda è il secondo
motivo è la paura e la paura di
confrontarsi con le proprie
responsabilità e la paura di
confrontarsi con il dolore degli altri
ecco allora noi nei momenti difficili di
crisi abbiamo una straordinaria risorsa
che sono le nostre emozioni
ma non sono le emozioni gli emoticon dei
telefonini non sono i messaggini che
mandiamo sono le emozioni che sentiamo
nel cuore e nella testa sono le emozioni
che dobbiamo utilizzare e modulare
modulare la paura e far emergere le
altre emozioni metterci nei panni degli
altri usare la massima espressione della
nostra intelligenza
l'empatia entrare in relazione con gli
altri non con i messaggini con le parole
e con i gesti
siete pronti per il vostro momento
morandi non credo che si possa essere
pronti però ci si può preparare e allora
ricordatevi quando quel momento verrà
perché verrà non è una questione se è
una questione quando ricordatevi di
usare le vostre emozioni
ricordatevi se il momento è vostro di
usare le parole ei gesti per chiedere
aiuto e non abbiate paura
se il momento è di qualcuno che vi è
vicino o anche di qualcuno che non
conoscete di fare il passo
le emozioni sono una straordinaria
risorsa non comprime tele non nascondete
le usatela e invece di chiudersi nel
silenzio di quel corridoio di linate
apritevi apritevi alla comunicazione
perché la comunicazione nei momenti di
difficoltà della vita e quella che vi
può aiutare
[Applauso]
[Musica]